my name is set upon bounce camp
vice-president Foundation a newly crated
foundation working provides innovation
and Russia's first time wearing no host
and his first time represent has spoken
foundation first question is what would
you like to be historically remembered
for I think a dream of everyone's person
is to be either through work or through
some personal children to do something
which stated history and the only thing
which stay in the history is when you do
something which can be simple or
complicated which changes people's life
it's a huge ambition these things happen
in historical you happen to be in
moments of history or in the projects
which do you have event year for the
development of the world
I started months ago please tell us what
you care about what future directions
you see contribute to improving the
state of the world once again we're
trying to create a completely new
framework for innovation on the
territory of Russia everyone knows that
Russian had good brains but also we know
sort of a very good infrastructure and
the first time we're creating to a city
which would have a new university I work
on five priority areas energy IT nuclear
space and science and we're trying to
create good conditions for the
scientists who before were emigrating
who now could stay and work in Russia
it's an ambitious project very young one
year very dynamic very fast and very
good in nature and I hope by successful
and he was successful there will be
something left and what's your favorite
Davos moment we're just starting this
few days personal favorite moment is
arrival the day before yesterday and
walking through a path it is no higher
than you are I haven't seen so much snow
for a long period of time but most
seriously speaking we're just starting
but we did already have a very nice
event
ACN received bright strong unleashing
energy innovation which was yesterday
and it was a very nice brainstorm kind
of thinking strategic event thinking how
to improve the world in 2012 20 on the
energy issue in the poor world where
most anticipated and we do hope